le gouvernement legault pourrait fermer
définitivement la porte à l'exploration
et l'exploitation des gisements de gaz
naturel et de pétrole c'est un
revirement pour un gouvernement qui dit
avoir un préjugé favorable envers les
projets créateurs de richesses et
d'emplois jonathan julien le ministre de
l'énergie et des ressources naturelles
bonsoir monsieur julien oui bonsoir
monsieur fillon est ce que c'est l'été
des volte face à la cac avec le rejet
finalement du projet gnl québec qui
aujourd'hui vous nous annoncez que vous
pensez sérieusement à arrêter
l'exploration et l'exploitation du
pétrole mais monsieur clients d'entrée
de jeu vous vous souviendrez qu'on a une
loi au québec sont les hydrocarbures un
règlement qui y perd au bus je suis là
en cours en mars dernier pour défendre
la loi et les règlements qu'on attend un
jugement de la cour sur justement cette
défense là essentiellement c'est par
rapport aux forages à proximité de
milieux hydriques au québec alors les
rivières les lacs et j'ai bien défendu
la loi et les règlements pour s'assurer
justement que les lacs les rivières au
québec soit protéger d'une éventuelle
exploitation ce que je demande à mon
ministère
ce qui est vrai c'est vous allez faire
une analyse sur tous les scénarios
potentiels suite à un jugement éventuel
qui devrait être cet automne pour qu'on
est devant nous toutes les possibilités
et qu'on fasse les meilleurs choix à la
lumière mains de jugement l'a donc
aujourd'hui on prend pas une décision
non mais clairement aujourd'hui je veux
avoir une analyse rigoureuse de tous les
scénarios dont celui éventuellement qui
pourraient d'exclure l'exploitation et
l'exploration des hydrocarbures au
québec il vous tente ce scénario là mais
c'est un scénario qui va être utilisé le
cas échéant où on a des risques c'est à
dire que je peux pour conclure
aujourd'hui quels seront le jugement de
la cour mais si par exemple
c'est un exemple on venait et valider
certains aspects du règlement qui vise à
protéger le milieu hydrique mais l'or
j'irai l'instinct un instant on doit
protéger le milieu hydriques au québec
donc dépendants du jugement dépendant de
la suite des choses on devra agir et
c'est pas vrai qu'on va attendre le
jugement pour s'y préparer ça serait
pour responsable je comprends le la
rhétorique là derrière sap et l'histoire
du jugement mais en même temps la caq a
été élu en 2018 comme étant un créateur
de richesses qui voulait développer les
énergies des ressources font partie de
sa une volte face de votre gouvernement
d'écouter la loi était adoptée juste
avant les élections la loi et les
règlements on ne jamais mis en doute
cette loi et ses règlements là on
convient également que pour nous la
transition énergétique et je suis
responsable la transition énergétique
c'est la voie de passage pour le québec
on le dit clairement en 2030 on va avoir
1,5 million de véhicules électriques en
2030 5 euros plus de ventes de véhicules
à essence en 2050 on veut la
carboneutralité donc on était six
concepts quand même avec ce qu'on dit
par rapport à la transition énergétique
et l'utilisation d'énergies fossiles il
est vrai monsieur fillion qu'encore
aujourd'hui au québec c'est plus de 50%
de l'énergie à peu près 55 % qui
provient d'énergies fossiles mais
clairement on s'en vont vers un
balancement vers l'énergie verte vers
les énergies renouvelables
hydroélectricité l'éolienne donc c'est
vers ce qu'on veut tendre oui c'est ça
mon on dirait que c'est comme une
nouvelle vocation là que vous vous
donnez moi je veux comprendre est-ce que
l'enjeu c'est les compensations parce
que ça pourrait coûter des milliards de
dollars il ya des centaines de permis
d'exploration qui existent qui sont
entre les mains des entreprises si vous
décidez
d'adopter le scénario de mettre fin à
l'exploration et l'exploitation ça va
vous coûter combien encore long et les
scénarios je peux pas vous révéler le
chef mais c'est certainement pas dans
les chiffres des milliards de dollars
que vous avez mentionné ces mots
écoutez c'est nettement moins d'un
milliard de da mais à la fin c'est
actuellement il ya des permis mais comme
vous dites monsieur fillion actuellement
au québec il ya pas d'exploration il
n'ya pas d'exploitation par rapport aux
hydrocarbures donc les permis qui sont
donnés c'est pour permettre à faire du
travail préalable à obtenir
éventuellement permis d'exploitation ou
d'exploration donc les sommes sont
investies c'est beaucoup plus en fin de
compte dans les recherches préliminaires
on n'est pas dans ces eaux là et encore
là aujourd'hui on nous dit pas la
conclusion mais je pense que comme
gouvernement responsable on doit faire
les analyses préalables avant le
jugement est ce que l'interdiction de
tout projet d'oléoduc ou de gazoducs
fait aussi partie la réflexion en ce
moment
pas du tout écouter c'est vrai sur la
loi sur les hydrocarbures on parle de
désertique mais on a pas d'intention par
rapport à une modification à l'intérieur
de la loi mais effectivement il fait
partie de la loi mais on s'en va vers ça
mais effectivement encore là
actuellement au québec et aucun projet
sur ce qu'on voit à l'horizon par
rapport à ces éléments là donc pour
avoir ses seins et les audi qui
s'apprend la régie de l'énergie qui se
penche là-dessus les ministères de
l'environnement au québec toute la
sécurité de l'eve du fédéral alors pour
nous le un projet comme celui là on le
voit pas poindre à l'horizon pénétration
de l'interdire ok donc je pense que je
comprends bien si un investisseur veut
investir au québec veut faire de
l'exploration puis éventuellement de
l'exploitation on est en train de fermer
la porte tranquillement là c'est à dire
qu'actuellement de noix et règlements
qui sont contester juridiquement et on
verra les conclusions de la cour à cet
effet l'eau mais c'est hors de question
qu'on va provenir préserver nos lacs et
nos rivières et nos ressources
naturelles au québec donc je pense qu'on
peut faire un et l'autre est
actuellement vers l'analyse la cour
jonathan juliet merci d'avoir été avec
nous
grand plaisir monsieur fillion pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit